foreign
[Music]
22 I'm James heal and each week on the
program we look at an issue in depth
that's dominating the news today we're
discussing the works of Roald Dahl and
made a controversy about sensitivity
readers changing his works I'm joined
today by Sam Leith The Spectators
literary editor hello Sam and welcome
Sam this Rouse blew up about a fortnight
ago can you talk us through how it came
to be
well there was a fantastic piece of
reporting in the Daily Telegraph
actually
um by three reporters where they noticed
and I don't know whether they've been
tipped off to it or what had happened
um but that Roald Dahl's entire Canon
was being reissued by Puffin or had been
reissued I think kind of on the quiet
um with a huge number of redactions and
revisions made in order to take out
language and ideas that could be
considered offensive or harmful so
you know out when fat phobia out went
all sorts of stuff that appeared
misogynistic or racist or you know even
questionable in any way you know mental
health shaming you name it which
obviously enrolled dull means quite a
lot of the material
I mean my
feeling like it was one of those things
that when noticed
it a lot of people jump very predictably
in a kind of cultural War Direction
um the sort of
those who I think instinctively were
always up for canceling Roald Dahl not
least since you know the news of his
personal anti-Semitism had
um you know massively sort of damaged
his reputation I mean it didn't his
reputation as a writer I don't think
because the none of that comes through
in the books but you know he was
considered sort of unwholesome and
there was certainly among people that
you know who would disposed that way
there was actually a sense of saying
look
you know why shouldn't you expunge the
you know racism sexism fat shaming all
that that stuff and make it more
politically correct because this is you
know children's literature and and
children need or want protecting from
that stuff
at the same time
um there's obviously an equally strong
you know outrage against the sort of
revisions from the sort of anti-work
types who said you know this is
censorship it's stalinism it's the woke
Stasi coming to destroy our childhoods
etc etc etc and
oh well In fairness we should note that
doll would absolutely have loathed it
um one of the nice developments that's
that's come out is the um
that just just recently somebody who was
actually writing a book about Francis
Bacon and following around with the tape
recorder
had recorded a conversation drunken
conversation between bacon and Dal in
which both of them talks about what you
know posterity and whether anyone should
change their work after they'd end up
apparently it's incredibly emphatic that
he thought you know essentially
political correctness as it would then
have been called
um was going to be you know utterly
destructive to his work and if anyone
changed it after his death
um he would send The Enormous Crocodile
to go and eat them
um I mean the only important to make
about this maybe is that you know tough
luck rolled um I mean
it notoriously the world doesn't
um
you know honor the dying wishes of
writers and thank God they don't or we
wouldn't have notoriously you know
Virgil or Kafka simply both of them
wanted their Works destroyed on their
deathbeds
um and I mean
dull might have been wise to put a
codecil in his will saying you know if
my work is to be published it should be
published unaltered and you know maybe
that would have been a good thing and
maybe that would have been a bad thing
but unfortunately his relics and
children and descendants
um inherited the copyrights and
therefore Canon did do what they damn
well like and you say there that you
know these have been done it seems to be
primarily for moral reasons or for the
idea that we should teach the children
you know the right way to think and feel
because you say that it was done quietly
you know and that the telegraph noticed
this this presumably would suggest that
it was meant to be done on the sly as it
were rather than for any kind of
commercial or marketing reasons what was
it okay for commercial thinking behind
this is is this popular is this what
readers want now
well I think
I think that's sort of an open question
I mean
obviously the doll
over the whole dial Canon is a
fantastically valuable commercial
property as we know it was sold to
Netflix for absolutely squillions
um it should be said actually that this
these changes weren't made as a result
of the Netflix sale or by Netflix
um this revision was kind of
ongoing at the time the sale was made
you know it already was already in place
um so I think the sales of Netflix is
2021 I think um
but I think to a certain extent yes they
wanted to Future proof the work because
they were very aware for example Dr Zeus
um a number 100 doctors use his titles
were taken out of circulation were
effectively kind of canceled so-called
because you know there were aspects of
them that were if you like Politically
Incorrect in ways that were considered
offensive and unacceptable
so they they sort of vanished and I
think there's a certain amount of you
know calculation they think you know we
don't want that to happen to doll
but the question of whether they were
they were intending to kind of
you know make the books more profitable
by making them more you know acceptable
in one age I think it's harder to say
um because I mean as you can see from
the backlash almost nobody
defended
these revisions
um quite the opposite I mean I I think
you know it's one of the cliches of
those on the right of the culture wars
that you know go woke go broke
and certainly that seems to be borne out
by the backlash I mean puffin
has had a terrible time of it and have
basically capitulated and in the last
week or so I think have announced that
in fact they're going to publish the
unexpigated editions alongside the
expirgated editions in a kind of
classics
range I mean
if I can kind of set out how I see it I
mean firstly I think it isn't a kind of
complete Innovation that there is this
anxiety about children's literature
shaping children's young minds um
through the whole history of children's
literature adults had been very aware
and very conscious and very anxious
about what's suitable for children about
the idea I think you know correctly that
what children read can be formative and
can shape their World Views and that
adult anxiety has expressed itself all
sorts of ways through history I mean you
know notoriously and sort of earliest
flowerings of children's literature in
sort of 17th and 18th centuries it was
basically Calvinists
um wrote These really kind of bloody
sanguinary frightening books
um designed to scare children you know
towards the church and to repentance
their sins
um
and there's a sort of inheritance
of that kind of calvinist view I think
that's now driving the idea that you
know there are certain heresies that
can't be allowed in children's
literature
um I think that the revisions the
problem is even if you were to defend
the principle
of revising darling we should say this
isn't censorship that's coming from
libraries or from the government or from
even
um published particularly it's it's the
copyright holders are simply reissuing
the text now we know that Dahl when he
was alive you know as the copyright
holder of Charlie and the Chocolate
Factory revised it to make the Oompa
Loompas less racist
um and so it's the idea this is a
complete work of vandalism that nobody
could ever revive these texts that
they're sacred seems to me to be kind of
nonsense and it's certainly not a kind
of attack on Free Speech being made by
some shadowy institution you know it's
it's the dullest state as was and now
Netflix that has sanctioned these
changes and of course as the copyright
holder um
you know you're entitled to do that
and if we see the principle that say you
know nobody's going to argue too much
that it's a you know utter work of
vandalism when Agatha Christie say to
revive to revise the title of her
um notorious novel that became known as
and then there were what there were none
uh which originally contained the n-word
in the title you know
if you see the principle that maybe
sometimes it might not be the worst
thing in the world to revise things
you nevertheless run up in the case of
the dial estate with the fact that it
was done so clumsily and crassly
I mean it's just been really badly done
even if you accept that maybe
having
um
you know which I don't think can be
dismissed out of hand the idea that if
say the books contain a lot of language
that's you know equates directly you
know being overweight with being
disgusting
you know that that can get fat kids
bullied in the playground and I don't
you know I I don't see that necessarily
you can dismiss that entirely out of
hand
um but if you're doing it as crashly as
they've done it you're going to find who
you Defenders but you mentioned the
crassness of it I also think perhaps one
of the reasons why this is such an
outcry is because it's children's books
you mentioned Agatha Christie you can
think of perhaps other adult works but
this is children's books and therefore
people think well hang on a sec because
there's something sort of slightly sins
here not least because of course Roald
Dahl was so beloved of so many children
and you do have you've written a lovely
article for The Spectator we have this
great line to talk about how Roald Dahl
recognizes that there's a wickedness in
children uh and you know he he has that
streak in himself and so is there
perhaps a danger that you know by doing
it in this way we therefore kind of make
it seem less authentic even if we try to
make them nicer as it were for children
well I think there's a lot to be
unpicked actually there um I mean do you
know that it's you know it's worse
because it's children's books
you know I think partly the strength of
reaction comes from a very adult
Nostalgia for the books of their own
childhood
so I mean you know if we're saying will
change language for adult books because
you know show me Agatha Christie we
mostly presumably say adults are more
robust to coming across offensive
language than children are so the idea
that you'd say oh we have to change this
for the adults but oh children no you
know let have it give them the n-word
um and so I I don't think they would be
more sacred
um if you like the text would be more
sacred because there were children's
books than because they're adults books
um
I think there is a central point though
that it's an adult anxiety not a
childish one and
the you know the reason Dahl seemed to
me to be kind of a special case is
because
Dahl's genius was precisely that kind of
adults didn't really like his books
because they didn't think they were
suitable for children his books are and
were even in their own generation
denounced as cruel vulgar amoral
um I'm a Humphrey Carpenter in his
classic study of children's literature
um says he he says he thinks Donald was
basically a moral I mean I take a
different view I think doll was fiercely
moral but he was kind of medieval in his
morality he was you know his world was
one in which which children touched up
such Delight
you know adults who weren't nice to
children were subject to incredible
violent Vengeance which children bloody
love and
you know the violence and aggression and
You Know Glee
that Dahl takes in the you know sticky
ends to which his villains come is what
what makes them so appealing to children
and I could make a point also that
the idea of sort of
trying to make things nice for children
so as to protect their young minds
they're selling children instinctively
resist
um I mean notoriously I think you know
when I was a kid
um this what what was then called the
Society
changed its name to scope because
was
um a playground insult of course what do
children do they started calling each
other scopers
you know it
the the children's cruelty can get
around the adults
um
around the adults kind of attempt to
protect them
you know every single time I think
children are a nastier as Dar recognized
and adults like to admit
and so much of Roald Dahl's
material is kind of
feeding into that is playing into that
and as I say he's sort of medieval
in the way that again
you know it's he he equates as you know
fairy tales do
physical Beauty with moral Beauty now
we've got a problem with that in our own
generation we don't like to fact shame
people we don't like to say that that
people are ugly and particularly we
don't like this idea
um which obviously is quite
you know unfounded in real life that
you know the goodies are all beautiful
and the Uglies are all Wicked and bad
and ugly and fat and evil
um and yet that goes through dial
absolutely like a stick of rock so
controlling the Chocolate Factory
yeah there is no way to change the story
sufficiently so that Augustus Gloop is
not a fat kid Augustus Gloop is gluttony
in a kind of medieval morality play
Incarnation he gets stuck in a chocolate
tube
um
you know so so the sort of um the
rewriters in this case the sensitivity
readers they're an all can't call them
fat so we're going to call them enormous
and elsewhere they have you know they
they took out they said we can't call
people mad because you know that's
mental health shaming so we'll have to
change to out of your mind which you
know
just read so the trouble the trouble is
a lot of this stuff is absolutely
pavement level and dull and you can't
really extract it and so I just wanna
can you put some sort of context and
what a context here on sensitivity
readers because I think this is the
first time that a lot of people will
have come across this how recent is this
as an innovation obviously we've always
seen kind of rewrites and things like
forwards but it used to be the case you
know you would have an updated forward
to a book trying to kind of
contextualize this seems to be a sort of
slightly new innovation or perhaps a new
spin on things can you just sort of say
how wide this practice is and whether
it's kind of reserved for the most
famous books presumably the most
commercial and sell the most so people
want to update them or whether this is
going to be something they want to see
more of in the future I can't speak for
the publishing industry
um as a whole I think it's it's wide
it's fairly widespread in large trade
Publishers it's becoming more so I think
it's particularly
common in children's and young adult
literature for some reason the sort of
ideological cancel culture Rouse that go
on seem to be really at their fiercest
in young adult literature and the idea
of sensitivity reader essentially is
it's someone who goes through a text
looking for ways in which the text might
be offensive
um it will talk they will look at ways
in which
an author who might be writing a
character or a situation that's outside
their own experience and here's one of
the you know big points of contention
about this because fiction writers will
say well look our job is to make stuff
up
um whereas sensitivity readers will tend
to say look you've you know produced say
a Native American character and you've
got them wearing a War Bonnet and that's
that's not cool because they'd only wear
these in certain circumstances or this
is
um and these get caricatured as kind of
you know politically correct censorship
all this I think again as with Dawn
rewrites it depends a bit how it's done
I mean say our sensitivity readers new
well not really when George Eliot wrote
Daniel duronda
she went to a rabbi and she said look
I'm writing a book about Jewish people
um
you know more about this subject than me
can you you know read my manuscript and
tell me whether I've got it right
um
and
you know so from in some senses being a
sensitivity reader shouldn't be a kind
of bogeyman it's simply an extension of
the function any good editor does which
is to say look
you've got the wrong Russian phrase here
or
if you write this in a certain way it is
going to look crass
but as I say the culture wars being as
they are
the issue has been kind of absolutely
dragged deep into it and of course the
other story that's come out now is that
the James Bond books are going to have
uh racial uh phrases and move from
removed from them I mean how different
is that Row from this rail and I just
wonder perhaps if you can see other
books are likely to be caught up in this
as well I know you can't speak for the
publishing industry sound but I just you
know do you think that this is going to
be something we see more often terms of
those books which are popular in the mid
to late 20th century perhaps all right
well I don't know I mean I think there
is a
you know particularly with adult books
um my instinct as a reader and as a kind
of critic is I think we basically for
the most part ought to leave them alone
because
you know you really are slightly erasing
the history of the Canon and partly
there's a sort of sort of what's left
um
in that I mean I I'm working at the
moment on a book about children's
literature in the history of children's
literature and I'm kind of astounded and
dismayed by how right up into the 80s
and I mean not quite the 90s but well
into the 80s
there was a sort of casual racism and
other ring
which would be you know very shocking to
readers now in all the books and you
know we're talking about I mean this
morning
you know I've been working away hard
reading Wind in the Willows right
Wind in the Willows this has got an
absolute Paragon a kind of Edwardian
innocence and yet when Toad when he's on
the run from you know having broken out
of jail
he has a run-in with a barge woman who's
barging a barge along the river and they
fall out with each other and he
denounces it as a common fat barge woman
with mottled arms
um
and like you know the the chocolate
people would be Charlie the Chocolate
Factory rewriters would be going through
that like a dulcers dose of salts
throughout the 19th century and early
20th century even in quite Progressive
children's writers you know you think of
e Nesbit you know she's a Fabian she's
kind of a very you know she's not like
sort of mad imperialist GA henti you
know she's she's considered sort of a
very forward-looking children's right
but they're absolutely stuffed with kind
of you know anti-semitic and racial
stereotypes with kind of really sort of
class snobbery I mean you know in in the
samiad there's a run-in with a butcher's
boy who's just completely innocent
character who's basically duffed up by
the main characters and he clearly
doesn't count
as as fully human as the nice middle
class
children
so if you go through unpicking and
rewriting everything
um I think you aren't going to be left
with all that much I mean with the Bond
books there's some pretty
dodgy stuff in that I mean it's actually
not the racism but misogyny generally
that's the problem with Bondo and is
that notorious line about the Tang of
rape approvingly noted in a room
um
and
again I just had to think I can see the
case for you know it doesn't hurt to
take out some of them you know
some of the more racist or fat phobic
stuff in dull if you can which is hard
um you know in the hopes that this maybe
makes makes the lives a slightly
overweight Children's School
playground's a bit easier I think when
you start kind of running a comb through
the adult Canon you are I mean I I hate
stud like a culture Warrior but you know
you're erasing literary history at least
making it it harder to
you know see how how these original
artifacts are
well thank you very much Sam appreciate
you joining us today on spectator TV
[Music]